there's a big game coming up and that
means that we all have permission to
punt our diets into the back field or
the next day or the next week and touch
down into a delicious game day feast and
here to show us how to put the pep in
snack presentation is my cutie of a
quarterback hey ross matthew hot head
hike
all right
listen
i am so excited to share these we are
teaming up with sam's club because
they're debuting their first ad in the
big game this year
and i'm going to show you how to take
some sam's club pre-made dishes add a
little vip twist so all your friends
will think everything is homemade and
they're a fancy party all right so every
game day starts with what ribs and wings
can i get an amen you need ribs and
wings i mean
wings are synonymous with game deck so
you can pick these up ready to go at
sam's club but i'm going to show you how
to elevate them a little bit so first
make sure you plate them okay and we're
going to put some chives and some sesame
seeds on the on the the wings look at
that just a little color takes us to the
next level boom it really does now it
looks like you made them yourself right
now i'm not kidding that that really
garnishes
like what takes it from you know a b to
an a total question so if you like that
look what i'm gonna put on these ribs
just a little parsley i had in the
fridge oh now are we gourmet all of a
sudden sorry color matters like it in
food it you eat with your eyes and those
pops of color make a huge difference
yeah boom can we can we hear it for that
just total
game change game changer it is a game
changer all right we're going to talk
about platters you have to put platters
out for your guests right and uh it's
all about the presentation so i just
picked up some um some pre-made sam's
club dips we've got spinach artichoke
avocado salsa roasted chili a
cauliflower dip so you're just going to
put them in little bowls yourself take
they come like this right we just have
little signs i just wrote what dip was
what they are so people know what
they're eating you know you could even
print this out and stick it on a
toothpick and put it in there too
barrymore are you ready to be put in the
game
always always all right i need your help
with this one here's the bread bowl
this is an easy way to wow your guests
okay we just got like an italian round
thing at the grocery store cool right
exactly and then we're gonna
we're gonna cut a little football shape
into it we've already started but just
you can just sort of eyeball it
take this out like this and then just
pull out a couple inches in there
we're gonna take the
gouda pimento cheese spread which i'm
sorry but pimento chee can we can i
please i would i would marry you but i'm
already taken
we're going to take this out
and fill up our little bowl now i'm
taking you somewhere wait till you see
how this finishes drew so
fill this up
and then
look what i'm going to do i slice little
peppers
and then i'm going to put it on so they
it looks like it's crosstalk it's the
stitches of a football
it's cute
how cute it's real cute is that it's
real cute are you ready
for i think your favorite part is it
sam's club cheesecake because that
really is my favorite cheesecake on
planet earth i have a history with it i
found this one cheesecake in this
amazing restaurant in texas and i was
like you have to tell me how who what
how because i was like i can never live
without this cheesecake and they said
you can get it at sam's club so
she will
stop talking about this ever been a big
sam's club cheesecake it really is the
best i've ever had well i have something
to tell you drew now at sands club drew
they actually have members mark
cheesecake miniatures right here
original chocolate caramel strawberry
and so what i suggest for the big game
is taking these little things we just
bought online and just decorate them a
football ball a goal pose how cute right
that's the best so all of this stuff is
so simple and so fun to do and you all
trust me all right follow sam's club on
instagram and twitter this sunday
because they're running a promotion with
chances to win some insane vip prizes
all right so head to sam's club.com vip
for all the details and good luck
yeah
okay well that's not all because sam's
club wants our studio audience to have a
feast of their own so you're all going
to go home with a sam's club plus
membership
free of charge but more importantly
you're gonna get to go home with a
hundred yeah
[Music]
you